llegar aquí
junto a esta espada para mí
es toda una vida una existencia está
para espada representa demasiado para
nosotros para nosotras
y quiero que nunca más esté enterrada
quiero que nunca más esté retenida
que solo se embargue como dijo su
propietario el libertador cuando haya
justicia en este país
que sea del pueblo
es la espada del pueblo
y por eso la queríamos aquí
en este momento y en este lugar
quizás para los próximos presidentes y
presidentas cuando se posesionen se
vuelva un hecho
permanente protocolario simbólico que
los acompañe siempre que las acompañe
siempre la espada libertaria de bolívar
[Aplausos]
indudablemente implica recorrer una vida
la vida inmensa que nunca se recorre
sola
aquí está mi madre clara
nada existiría en mí en este momento sin
ella
aquí está mi padre gustavo
caribeño aquí están mis hermanos adriana
y juan que me aguantaban y aún me
aguantan
aquí están mis hijos nicolás petro
nicolás alcocer andrea y andrés
sofía y antonella mis pequeñas que
florecen de corazón y alma
aquí está verónica alcocer quien me ha
acompañado
quien me ha dado descendencia la vida
misma
quien el amor ha hecho todo posible aquí
no estará para acompañarme solamente
sino para acompañar a las mujeres de
colombia en su esfuerzo para salir
adelante
para crear
para luchar para hacer
para superar la violencia dentro y fuera
de las familias para construir la
política del amor
aquí está como en el recorrido necesite
mi existencia al pueblo
las manos humildes del obrero
aquí están las campesinas y las que
barren las calles aquí están los
corazones del trabajo las ilusiones de
quien sufre aquí están las mujeres
trabajadoras que me han abrazado siempre
cuando te caigo cuando me siento débil
el amor del pueblo y el amor al pueblo a
la gente que sufre excluida
es ese amor
el que me mantiene aquí para unir y
construir ahora una nación
así acababa cien años de soledad
de nuestro querido gabriel garcía
márquez
abro comillas
todo lo escrito en ellos era irrepetible
desde siempre y para siempre porque las
estirpes condenadas a cien años de
soledad no tenían una segunda
oportunidad sobre la tierra
cierra comillas
los colombianos y las colombianas
hemos sido muchas veces en nuestra
historia
enviados a la condena de lo imposible a
la falta de oportunidades
a los no rotundos quiero decirles a
todos
los colombianos y todas las colombianas
que me están escuchando en esta plaza de
bolívar en los alrededores en toda
colombia y en el exterior que hoy
empieza nuestra segunda
oportunidad
[Música]
nos la hemos ganado
se la han ganado
su esfuerzo valió y valdrá la pena es la
hora del cambio
nuestro futuro no está escrito
somos dueños del estero y del papel y
podemos escribirlo juntos en paz y en
unión hoy empieza la colombia de lo
posible estamos acá contra todo
pronóstico
contra una historia que decía que nunca
íbamos a gobernar
contra los de siempre
contra los que no querían soltar el
poder
pero lo logramos
hicimos posible lo imposible
con trabajo
recorriendo y escuchando con ideas
con amor
con el corazón y con el cerebro con
esfuerzo desde hoy
empezamos a trabajar para que más
imposibles sean posibles en colombia si
pudimos
podremos
[Música]
que la paz sea posible
tenemos que terminar de una vez y para
siempre con seis décadas de violencia y
conflicto armado yo diría con dos siglos
de guerra permanente la guerra eterna la
guerra perpetua de colombia se puede
cumpliremos el acuerdo de paz
seguiremos
[Música]
a rajatabla las recomendaciones del
informe de la comisión de la verdad
que nos cuenta de muertos
depende de desde qué fecha
comencemos a contar cuando comenzaba a
contar la comisión de la verdad con todo
hasta la fecha
800 mil muertos por la violencia
muertos colombianos muertos colombianas
la mayoría humildes
no podemos seguir en el país de la
muerte
tenemos que construir el país de la vida
y trabajaremos de manera incansable para
llevar paz y tranquilidad a cada rincón
de colombia este es el gobierno de la
vida de la paz y así será recordado
la paz es posible si desatamos en todas
las regiones de colombia el diálogo
social para encontrarnos en medio de las
diferencias para expresarnos y ser
escuchados para buscar a través de la
razón los caminos comunes de la
convivencia es la sociedad toda la que
debe dialogar sobre cómo no matarnos y
sobre cómo progresar
en los diálogos regionales vinculantes
convocamos a todas las personas
desarmadas
para encontrar los caminos del
territorio que permitan una convivencia
no importa los conflictos que allí haya
se trata precisamente de evidenciar los
a través de la palabra de intentar sus
soluciones a través de la razón es más
democracia más participación lo que
propongo para terminar con la violencia
pero convocamos también a todos los
armados a dejar las armas en las
nebulosas del pasado a aceptar
beneficios jurídicos a cambio de la paz
a cambio de la no repetición
definitiva de la violencia a trabajar
como dueños de una economía próspera
pero legal que acabe con el atraso de
las regiones
para que la paz sea posible en colombia
necesitamos dialogar dialogar mucho
entendernos buscar los caminos comunes
producir cambios
la paz implica que cambiemos
indudablemente
claro que la paz es posible si se cambia
por ejemplo la política contra las
drogas
vista como una guerra
llamada la guerra contra las drogas por
una política de prevención fuerte del
consumo en las sociedades desarrolladas
es hora de una nueva convención
internacional que acepte que la guerra
contra las drogas ha fracasado
rotundamente
que ha dejado un millón de
latinoamericanos asesinados
la mayoría colombianos
durante estos últimos 40 años y que deja
70.000 norteamericanos muertos por
sobredosis cada año por drogas que
ninguna se produce en américa latina'
que la guerra contra las drogas
fortaleció las mafias y debilitó los
estados
que la guerra contra las drogas ha
llevado a los estados a cometer crímenes
nuestro estado ha cometido crímenes
y ha evaporado el horizonte de la
democracia
vamos a esperar que otro millón de
latinoamericanos caigan asesinados y que
se lleven a 200 mil los muertos anuales
por sobredosis en los eeuu
vamos a esperar que los próximos 40 años
otro millón de latinoamericanos
caiga bajo el homicidio y dos millones
800 mil norteamericanos
mueran por sobredosis
o más bien
cambiamos el fracaso
por un éxito que permita que colombia y
latinoamérica puedan vivir en paz
llegó el momento de cambiar la política
antidrogas en el mundo para que permita
la vida y para que no genere la muerte
que nos quieren apoyar en la paz nos
dicen una y otra vez en todos los
discursos
pues cambien la política antidrogas que
está en sus manos
en el poder mundial en las naciones
unidas el poder hacerlo
que la igualdad sea posible
el 10 por ciento de la población
colombiana
tiene el 70 por ciento de la riqueza
es un despropósito
y es una verdadera moralidad
no naturalicemos la desigualdad y la
pobreza
no es cierto que el mundo sea igual no
es cierto que en la mayoría de los
países del mundo esta desigualdad social
que tenemos en colombia
exista
somos una de las sociedades más
desiguales socialmente en todo el
planeta tierra y esa es una aberración
que no podemos continuar si queremos ser
una nación si queremos vivir en paz
[Aplausos]
no miremos para otro lado
no seamos cómplices
con voluntad
políticas de redistribución y un
programa de justicia vamos a hacer una
colombia más igualitaria y con más
oportunidades para todos y todas
la igualdad es posible si somos capaces
de crear riqueza de generar riqueza para
todos y todas
y si somos capaces de distribuirla más
justamente
por eso proponemos una economía basada
en la producción
el trabajo y el conocimiento y es por
ello por lo que proponemos una reforma
tributaria que genere
justicia
el llevar una parte de la riqueza de las
personas que más tienen y más ganan para
abrirle las puertas de la educación a
toda la niñez y la juventud no debe ser
mirado como un castigo o un sacrificio
es simplemente el pago solidario que
alguien afortunado hace a una sociedad
que le permite y le garantiza la fortuna
si somos capaces de llevar una parte de
la riqueza que se crea a los niños y
niñas desnutridas a través de algo tan
simple como pagar los impuestos de ley
seremos más justos y estaremos más en
paz
no es un asunto sólo de caridad es un
asunto de solidaridad humana la
solidaridad es lo que ha permitido que
los pueblos sobrevivan y logren las
máximas conquistas de la cultura y de la
civilización
no hemos avanzado como humanidad
compitiendo no es cierto
lo hemos hecho ayudándonos
por eso estamos vivos en este planeta
seremos iguales cuando el que más tiene
al pagar sus impuestos lo haga con gusto
con orgullo sabedor que ayudará a su
prójimo niño niña bebé joven mujer viejo
a crecer sano a pensar a vivir con la
plenitud que da la nutrición y la
educación del cerebro y del alma
la solidaridad está en el impuesto que
paga el que puede pagarlo y en el gasto
del estado que va a quienes lo necesitan
por su infancia por su juventud por su
vejez el gasto del estado no es para las
mafias políticas es para la gente del
pueblo
por eso hemos planteado
una reforma tributaria
una reforma de la salud y de las
pensiones
una reforma del contrato laboral
una reforma de la educación
por eso hemos priorizado en el
presupuesto la infraestructura de la
educación
de la salud del agua potable de los
distritos de riego y de los caminos
vecinales
los impuestos no serán confiscatorios
simplemente justos en un país que debe
reconocer como aberración la enorme
desigualdad social en la que vivimos en
un estado que debe proteger la
transparencia del gasto y en una
sociedad que se merece el derecho de
vivir en paz
ser una sociedad del conocimiento
es decir una sociedad donde todos sus
integrantes tengan el máximo de
escolaridad y cultura no es una utopía
pueblos más pobres que nosotros hace
décadas son ahora sociedades del
conocimiento
solo porque invirtieron durante décadas
y con prioridad en la educación pública
de sus pueblos
llegó el momento de devolverle la deuda
a nuestra educación
para que alcance a todas y todos y sea
de calidad
llegó el momento de ser conscientes que
hoy el hambre avanza
que avanza por todo el mundo porque se
derrumbó una idea de seguridad
alimentaria basada exclusivamente en el
comercio internacional
el comercio internacional en sí mismo no
es ni positivo ni negativo
pero si no se maneja con inteligencia y
se planifica puede destruir economías y
vidas
el mundo hoy aprende la importancia de
la soberanía alimentaria
la soberanía alimentaria es la garantía
que toda sociedad debe tener para
consumir sus nutrientes indispensables
colombia es un país que debe y puede
gozar de soberanía alimentaria para
lograr que el hambre sea cero
una misión del estado con todo el sector
privado que quiera unirse
debe garantizar la plena alimentación
sana de toda la sociedad colombiana y
lograr incluso excedentes para la
exportación
en la tierra en donde el ser humano
descubrió el maíz
debemos producir de nuevo maíz
el estado tendrá que brindar riegos
créditos técnicas semillas mejoradas
protección el campesinado y una empresa
privada puede brindar el trabajo y el
empeño cotidiano para lograr que
nuestros campos vuelvan a producir los
alimentos que necesita nuestro pueblo
volveremos a construir distritos de
riego con el ejército y casas campesinas
y caminos vecinales
con los soldados de la patria
ejército sociedad y producción
pueden unirse en una nueva ética social
indestructible los helicópteros y los
aviones y las fragatas no sólo sirven
para bombardear o disparar también
sirven para crear la primera
infraestructura de movilidad de la salud
preventiva del pueblo colombiano
solo si producimos seremos ricos y
prósperos como sociedad la riqueza está
en el trabajo y el trabajo es cada vez
más de la inteligencia
por eso a partir de hoy
todos los bienes en extinción de dominio
o extinguidos de la sae
pasarán a ser la base de una nueva
economía productiva administrada por las
organizaciones campesinas por las
cooperativas urbanas de jóvenes
productivos y por las asociaciones
populares femeninas
que la igualdad de género sea posible no
podemos seguir permitiendo que las
mujeres tengan menos oportunidades
laborales y que ganen menos que los
hombres
que tengan que dedicar el triple o
cuádruple de horas a las tareas del
cuidado que estén menos representadas en
nuestras instituciones
ya es hora de combatir todas esas
desigualdades y equilibrar la balanza
que el futuro verde sea posible
el cambio climático es una realidad y es
urgente
no lo dicen las izquierdas ni las
derechas lo dice la ciencia
tenemos y podemos encontrar un modelo
que sea sostenible económica social y
ambientalmente
sólo habrá un futuro si equilibramos
nuestras vidas y la economía de todo el
mundo con la naturaleza
la ciencia ha anunciado la extinción
posible de la especie humana en apenas
uno o dos siglos por los efectos en la
salud que traería la crisis climática
uno o dos siglos nos quedan
el virus del cob y le mostró a toda la
humanidad
la alerta viva y real de esta
posibilidad
la ciencia no parece equivocarse por eso
desde esta colombia le pedimos al mundo
acción y no hipocresía
nosotros estamos dispuestos a transitar
a una economía sin carbón y sin petróleo
pero poco ayudamos a la humanidad con
ello
no somos nosotros los que emitimos los
gases de efecto invernadero
son los ricos del mundo quienes lo hacen
acercando al ser humano a su extinción
pero nosotros si tenemos
la media la mayor esponja de absorción
de estos gases después de los océanos la
selva amazónica
uno de los pilares del equilibrio
climático y de la vida en el planeta es
la selva amazónica
vamos a dejar que se destruya esa selva
para llegar al punto de no retorno en la
extinción de la humanidad
vamos a salvarla con la humanidad misma
que quiere seguir viviendo en esta
tierra donde está el fondo mundial para
salvar la selva amazónica
los discursos no la salvarán
podemos convertir a toda la población
que hoy habita la amazonía colombiana
en una población cuidadora de la selva
pero necesitamos los fondos del mundo
para hacerlo
si es tan difícil conseguir esos dineros
que las tasas carbón que los bonos
verdes que los fondos del clima pactados
deberían otorgar para salvar algo tan
esencial
entonces le propongo a la humanidad
cambiar deuda externa por gastos
internos para salvar y recuperar
nuestras selvas bosques y humedales
[Aplausos]
disminuyan la deuda externa y gastaremos
el excedente en salvar la vida humana
si el fm y ayuda a cambiar deuda por
acción concreta contra la crisis
climática
tendremos una nueva economía próspera y
una nueva vida para la humanidad
se acabaron los no se pueden no siempre
fue así hoy empieza la colombia de lo
posible
hoy empieza nuestra segunda oportunidad
desde hoy soy el presidente de toda
colombia y de todos los colombianos y
colombianas
es mi deseo y mi deber
colombia no es solo bogotá el gobierno
del cambio será descentralizado les
prometo que vamos a estar y trabajar en
todo el país
desde leticia hasta punta gallinas desde
cabo manglares hasta isla san jose
duele mucho la ausencia del estado
en muchos puntos del país ya no más voy
a trabajar para que el lugar de
nacimiento
no condicione tu futuro y para que el
estado diga presente en cada rincón de
colombia
agradezco la presencia de presidentes
presidentas y otros representantes de
los pueblos hermanos de latinoamérica
y del mundo todo en tiempos en los que
vemos a naciones hermanas entre sí
bombardear se matarse acribillar se aquí
en el corazón de colombia en el corazón
de latinoamerica hay una decena de
presidentes y presidentas de la región
con diversidad ideológica y diferentes
trayectorias pero todos unidos y unidas
compartiendo esta verdadera fiesta de la
democracia
ya es hora de dejar atrás los bloques
los grupos y las diferencias ideológicas
para trabajar juntos
entendamos de una vez y para siempre
es mucho más lo que nos une que lo que
nos separa y que juntos somos más
fuertes
hagamos realidad esa unidad con la que
enseñaron nuestros héroes como bolívar
san martín artigas sucre o higgins no es
una utopía ni el romanticismo
es el camino para hacernos fuertes en
este mundo complejo si somos poder del
conocimiento
si somos poder de la economía si somos
el poder de la vida si actuamos juntos
la voz de américa latina' se escuchará
en el concierto de los pueblos del mundo
hoy necesitamos estar más juntos y
unidos que nunca como dijo alguna vez
simón bolívar abro comillas
la unión debe salvarnos como nos
destruirá la división si llega a
introducirse entre nosotros cierro
comillas
que se acabe la división de américa
latina'
pero la unidad latinoamericana
no puede ser una retórica un mero
discurso
acabamos de vivir quizás lo peor de la
pandemia del cobi y américa latina no
fue capaz de juntarse de coordinarse
para comprar las vacunas más baratas
prácticamente fue usada sin capacidad de
negociación
dispersa en sus gobiernos
vamos a tener una latinoamérica sin
capacidad de investigación científica
una latinoamérica sin capacidad de
coordinar sus servicios de salud sin
capacidad de coordinar las compras de
medicamentos de manera unificada
latinoamérica se juntan algunas
instituciones pero no en proyectos
concretos
hemos acaso logrado la conexión de todas
nuestras redes de energía eléctrica
hay una red de energía eléctrica que
cubra toda américa
hemos logrado acaso que las fuentes de
nuestras energías sean limpias
no es acaso hora de impulsar a las
empresas petroleras
públicas de propiedad estatal y a
nuestras empresas de transmisión
eléctrica a construir el instrumento
empresarial y financiero latinoamericano
que aboque las inversiones en la
generación de las energías limpias y en
la transmisión de esa energía a escala
continental
colombia hará su énfasis internacional
en alcanzar los acuerdos más ambiciosos
posibles para frenar el cambio climático
y defender la paz mundial
no queremos que ninguno
pero ningún país
invada a otro
no estamos con la guerra
estamos con la vida
buscaremos mayores alianzas con áfrica
de donde provenimos
buscaremos una alianza de pueblos afros
en américa
buscaremos que están andrés sea un
centro de salud cultural y educativo del
caribe antillano
de allí de san andrés de su pueblo
raizal
saldrán todos los embajadores y
embajadoras de colombia para los países
en las antillas
buscaremos una alianza con el mundo
árabe en el camino de transitar hacia
las nuevas economías des carbonizadas
buscaremos juntar nuestra buena aventura
y nuestro tumaco con el este asiático
rico y productivo
[Aplausos]
nuestro himno que es uno de los más
lindos del mundo dice sentir o padecer
colombia acumulas siglos de padecimiento
una madre que no puede darle de comer a
su hijo lo padece un joven que emigra
porque no encuentra oportunidades la
padece una abuela o un abuelo que no
tiene una pensión digna la padece la
colombia que soñamos la colombia que
queremos la colombia que nos merecemos
en la colombia que queremos sentir la
colombia que vibra que se esfuerza que
añora y trabaja para alcanzar la paz que
quiere una tierra próspera con igualdad
de posibilidades
indistintamente del lugar donde se nació
independientemente como se apellida en
sus padres o cuál sea su color de piel
esa la colombia que queremos sentir y
por la que trabajaremos hasta el último
día de nuestro mandato
en este primer discurso como presidente
de colombia
frente al poder legislativo y frente a
mi pueblo quiero compartir mi decálogo
de gobiernos y mis compromisos
oficiales de bolívar descansen
tengo 10 compromisos
primero
trabajaré para conseguir la paz
verdadera y definitiva
como nadie como nunca vamos a cumplir el
acuerdo de paz y a seguir las
recomendaciones de la comisión de la
verdad el gobierno de la vida es el
gobierno de la paz la paz es el sentido
de mi vida es la esperanza de colombia
no podemos fallarle a la sociedad
colombiana los muertos se lo merecen los
vivos lo necesitan la vida debe ser la
base de la paz una vida justa y segura
una vida para vivir sabroso para vivir
feliz
para que la dicha y el progreso sean
nuestra identidad
cuidaré de nuestros abuelos y abuelas de
nuestros niños y niñas de las personas
con discapacidad de las personas a las
que la historia o la sociedad ha
marginado
haremos una política de cuidados para
que nadie en mayúscula se quede atrás
somos una sociedad solidaria que se
preocupa y ocupa del prójimo que su
gobierno también lo sea
haremos una política sensible al
sufrimiento y al dolor ajeno con
herramientas y soluciones para crear
igualdad 3
gobernar con iu para las mujeres de
colombia
hoy aquí empieza un gobierno paritario
con un ministerio de la igualdad
al fin
con nuestra vicepresidenta y ministra
francia márquez vamos a trabajar para
que el género no determine cuántas
cuánto ganas ni cómo vives
queremos igualdad real y seguridad para
que las colombianas puedan caminar
tranquilas y no temer por sus vidas
dialogar con todos y todas sin
excepciones ni exclusiones
este será un gobierno de puertas
abiertas para todo aquel que quiera
dialogar sobre los problemas de colombia
se llame como se llame
venga de donde venga lo importante no es
de dónde venimos
sino a dónde vamos
nos une la voluntad de futuro no el peso
del pasado
vamos a construir un gran acuerdo
nacional
para fijar la hoja de ruta de la
colombia de los próximos años el diálogo
será mi método los acuerdos mi objetivo
5 escucharé a las colombianas y
colombianos como lo he venido haciendo
en todos estos años no se gobierna a
distancia alejado del pueblo y
desconectado de sus realidades
todo lo contrario se gobierna escuchando
vamos a diseñar mecanismos y dinámicas
para que todo colombiano se sienta
escuchado en este gobierno
no quedaré atrapado entre las cortinas
de la burocracia
estaré cerca de los problemas
caminaré al lado y junto a los
colombianos de todos los rincones
ojala me abran las casas para dormir
como el campesino cafetero de anserma
como la señora pobre de quibdó
como el pescador del río magdalena en el
tolima
solo quien está cerca puede entender y
ponerse en el lugar del otro
defenderé a los colombianos y
colombianas de las violencias y
trabajaré para que las familias se
sientan seguras y tranquilas lo haremos
con una estrategia integral de seguridad
con la seguridad humana
colombia necesita una estrategia que
vaya desde los programas de prevención
desde la redención social desde acabar
con el hambre hasta la persecución de
las estructuras criminales y la
modernización de las fuerzas de
seguridad
las vidas salvadas serán nuestro
principal indicador de éxito la
seguridad se miden vidas no en muertos
cuando la seguridad se mide en muertos
llevan al estado al crimen y este estado
no está por el crimen atroz este estado
está para ser un estado social de
derecho
el crimen se combate de muchas maneras
todas imprescindibles quiero defender a
las familias colombianas de la
inseguridad diaria y cotidiana sea de la
violencia machista o de cualquier otra
violencia
lucharé contra la corrupción
con manos firmes sin miramientos
un gobierno de cero tolerancia
vamos a recuperar lo que se robaron
vigilar
para que no se vuelva a hacerlo y
transformar el sistema
para desincentivar este tipo de
prácticas
ni familia ni
amigos ni compañeros ni colaboradores
nadie queda excluido del peso de la ley
del compromiso contra la corrupción
y de mi determinación para luchar contra
ella desde hoy los cuerpos de
inteligencia del estado no perseguirán
la oposición política ni la prensa libre
ni el poder judicial ni el que piensa ni
la que piensa diferente
hoy el principal objetivo de los cuerpos
de la inteligencia del estado
es ubicar y combatir la corrupción
[Aplausos]
protegeré nuestro suelo y subsuelo
nuestros mares y ríos
nuestro aire y cielo nuestros paisajes
nos definen y nos llenan de orgullo
y por eso no voy a permitir que la
avaricia de unos pocos ponga en riesgo
nuestra biodiversidad
vamos a enfrentar
la deforestación
descontrolada de nuestros bosques e
impulsar el desarrollo de las energías
limpias y renovables
colombia será potencia mundial de la
vida
el planeta tierra es la casa común de
los seres humanos y colombia desde su
enorme riqueza natural va a liderar esta
lucha por la vida planetaria
desarrollar e la industria nacional la
economía popular y el campo colombiano
priorizaremos a la mujer campesina a la
mujer de la economía popular
indudablemente al microempresario y al
pequeño y mediano
empresario de colombia pero esta
invitación
es a producir es a trabajar es a ser
conscientes de que sólo seremos una
sociedad rica
si trabajamos
y que el trabajo cada vez más en el
siglo 21 es una propiedad del
conocimiento del cerebro de la
inteligencia humana vamos a acompañar y
apoyar a todo aquel que se esfuerce por
colombia el campesino la campesina que
se levanta al alba el artesano la
artesana que mantiene viva nuestra
cultura el empresario la empresaria que
crea trabajo
el trabajador y la trabajadora cultural
que construye la sensibilidad de la
sociedad humana la ciencia la cultura y
el conocimiento
es el combustible verdadero del siglo 21
vamos a desarrollar la sociedad del
conocimiento y la tecnología
cumpliré y haré cumplir nuestra
constitución
la que dice en su artículo 1
abro comillas
colombia es un estado social de derecho
organizado en forma de república
unitaria descentralizada
con autonomía de sus entidades
territoriales
democrática
participativa y pluralista
fundada en el respeto de la dignidad
humana en el trabajo y la solidaridad de
las personas que la integran y en la
prevalencia del interés general
cierra comillas
desarrollaremos también una nueva
cobertura legal para ser sostenible
justo e igualitario nuestro desarrollo
la ley como dice paolo flores d'arcais
es el poder de los que no tienen poder
necesitamos mejores leyes nuevas leyes
al servicio de las grandes mayorías y
garantizar su cumplimiento
confío mucho en que los debates en
nuestro congreso de la república sea
fructífero y ofrezca resultados para la
sociedad colombiana
hay muchas tareas y confío plenamente en
los nuevos representantes de la sociedad
colombiana en el congreso
nuevos y viejos
y finalmente una idea colombia
uniremos entre todos y todas
a nuestra querida colombia
tenemos que decirle basta la división
que nos enfrenta como pueblo
yo no quiero dos países como no quiero
dos sociedades
quiero una colombia fuerte justa y unida
los retos y desafíos que tenemos como
nación
exigen una etapa de unidad y consensos
básicos
es nuestra responsabilidad
termino aquí con lo que me dijo una niña
aru acá hace tres días en la ceremonia
de posesión ancestral que hicimos en el
corazón del mundo como le dicen los
hijos de la sierra nevada de santa marta
abro comillas
para armonizar la vida para unificar los
pueblos
para sanar la humanidad
sintiendo el dolor de mi pueblo de mi
gente aquí este mensaje de luz y verdad
es se esparza por tus venas me decía por
tu corazón y se convierta en actos de
perdón y reconciliación
mundial pero primero en nuestros
corazones
primero en mi corazón
gracias
[Aplausos]
unidad
es para ella la niña vaca
y para todos los niños y niñas de
colombia
niños y niñas colombianos
tenemos una segunda oportunidad bajo los
cielos de la tierra
gracias
[Aplausos]